welcome back now events have been held
across the UK today to Mark the 75th
anniversary of the arrival of Empire
Windrush at Tilbury docks in Essex the
first ship that brought workers from the
Caribbean in 1948. it's been described
as a Bittersweet anniversary because for
all the celebrations of the contribution
that those people made to life in
Britain there are also recent memories
of the Scandal over the way some members
of that generation were threatened with
detention and deportation shiman Freeman
Powell reports they've come to seek work
in Britain it's been 75 years since the
Empire Windrush sailed to the docks of
Tilbury they begin their new life over
here and on it around 500 Caribbean men
women and children about to shape the
course of British history
seven decades later descendants of those
first pioneers retrace their steps I
truly believe that we can carry this on
and carry on a legacy for our children
and their children
so yeah it makes me feel really proud
they came because they were invited
answering a call from the motherland to
help build the country back after two
world wars
was among them a veteran who moved from
Jamaica to Bristol in 1968 and today he
celebrated from an event in Wales
there are extraordinary
group of people who have contributed so
much
the king he was born the year the ship
arrived also recognized the defining
moment in history
in London celebrations kicked off at
Waterloo Station where thousands of
Caribbean migrants would have once to
pass through then representatives of the
pioneering generation embarked on a walk
to a service in their honor
a moment to remember the history
of that have been threatened by the
ongoing Windrush scandal
it's easy to celebrate and get carried
away and have a party and have a good
time but actually the most important
thing is that people need to be
compensated but they also need their
status and whilst the past and present
struggles were acknowledged the
contribution was the main focus of the
day whether that be the food the clothes
the music all of which is becoming part
of mainstream Society I have a
granddaughter that's going to be
arriving the first 2nd of July hopefully
and I want her to know what that
generation gave
today wasn't just about the first
arrivals or the thousands that followed
it was also an opportunity for the
hundreds of thousands of winrush
descendants to celebrate those who paved
the way Shimon Freeman Powell Sky News
now to Mark the anniversary King Charles
commissioned 10 portraits of Windrush
Elders painted by black artists that
have now gone on public view in
Edinburgh they were also shown to the
people who sat for them at an event at
Buckingham Palace last week now the
former children's TV presenter florella
Benjamin who's now a liberal Democrat
peer helped organize the portraits and I
spoke to her about the anniversary and
about her experience of coming to this
country from the Caribbean I began by
asking her what Windrush means to her
everything
windrushes me I'm part of that Windrush
generation I came to Britain when I was
10. from Trinidad
and when I lived in Trinidad my first 10
years in living in Trinidad I felt loved
because I had wonderful parents I
celebrated everything that was British I
was told I was part of the motherland
and I had that sense of Pride but when I
came here to Britain
it wasn't like that I didn't feel as if
I belonged and it was a very tough uh
four years in England having to justify
my existence so I fought every day and
the impacts that that generation has had
your generation and of course the
subsequent generations of those of us
that are children of people who came or
grandchildren people who came during
Windrush what kind of impact we had on
on this country enormous impact I came
here as I said a 10 year old 1960 and
what I've tried to do and thousands and
hundreds of other people like myself is
to contribute to British Society through
education through Commerce through the
Arts through fashion through politics we
have actually made a contribution we've
helped to rebuild Britain when Britain
was on its leads we came here you know
quite openly quite happy to join in and
try and make the country great even
though we were treated badly until to go
back to where we came from well that's
the point despite those hostilities I
mean there is a school of thought that
after all those hostilities that people
face here they should have gone home to
the Caribbean and helped build up that
place I I guess that you don't agree
with that sort of that argument when I
came here I lived in one room
eight people my mom my dad and my five
brothers and sisters we lived in one
room you wouldn't want people in
Trinidad to know that's what you've come
to so there's this sense of you know
some people did go back uh not everybody
stayed but you know as a child I didn't
have a say but I came to Britain or not
I had to just do what my parents did and
I came to what I thought was a Land of
Hope and glory and so growing up here in
Britain I I decided to play my part here
but I've also played my part in the
Caribbean when I worked to the window in
Rush Monument I was in charge of putting
up the Windrush monument at Waterloo
Station and I made sure that Caribbean
people were connected with that and we
got a Jamaican sculptor to actually
design the monument and when people see
it they weep because some people who are
now here they were what I call the Left
Behind children they were they they they
were rejected and when they came to
Britain they thought they would be
embraced but again they were rejected so
when grown men's in their 70s and their
ages when they see this Monument they
weep because now what Windrush 75 is
doing is allowing people to tell their
story untold stories and that's why I I
want to celebrate both the Caribbean and
Britain and the king in fact I think he
understands this too because he asked me
to chair the Windrush portrait committee
because of the Windrush commemoration
committee he asked me to chair this
committee and what he wanted to do was
to commission 10 portraits of Windrush
elders and they're all over the age of
90. I chose the people who were to be uh
because it's very hard there are so many
people who've made so many contributions
it was difficult to decide who should be
chosen but we thought if they were over
90 you could say we're celebrating
Windrush nobility we're standing on the
shoulders of people who've done great
things and paved the way for us in the
future with the King now what's his
feeling is as to how important this
moment is terribly important because he
asked me to chair the committee when he
was Prince Charles uh and when I he
became king I thought maybe he didn't
want to do it anymore but no no no he
was very much part of it we decided that
all the artists should be black arches
because we want to actually highlight
this the challenge of black arches that
we have he won ever he asked me oh why
am I doing the right thing floella so he
really is interested to make sure he
gets it right he himself mentioned his
sort of uh extreme sorrow in the British
government and the Royal Family's
involvement in the in the slave trade do
you think that sense of sorry that he
expressed it is enough could he be doing
more I know he's brought in a commission
to look at it of projects to look at the
Royal Family's links he's listening and
he wants to do whatever he can but
remember it's the government who's got
to make the final decisions he can say
what he likes to say the people who
actually make those real decisions about
reparation about slavery about how we
make those changes is the government so
we'll to the government and what I say
to black people is vote because if you
have the right person representing you
in Parliament you will get the right
decisions made and the decisions you
want to be made it's no point saying why
can't this happen why isn't that
happening if you haven't voted politics
belongs to all of us you mentioned the
the wonderful monument in Waterloo
Station that you were involved in how
did you um become chair of the Windrush
committee because of the windrow Scandal
I think suddenly government realized
something had to be done and I got a
call from number 10 to say lady Benjamin
we've decided to have a Windrush day and
we're going to give 500
000 pounds to Windrush projects every
year but most of all we want to create a
national Windrush monument and we'd like
you to chair it I couldn't believe it to
me it became a labor of love because I
knew how many people had suffered the
indignity the hatred the violence the
rejection because I have suffered it
I've been spat upon I've been told go
back to where you've come from but I dug
deep and I believed in who I was and I
had parents who told me how much they
loved me and and that sense of worth
that you have and of course that should
be engendered to everyone has been lost
by lots of those people in that Windows
generation who were caught up in the
Scandal they remember recommendations
that were accepted at the time by uh the
then Home Secretary and some have now
been
it's been decided they're not going to
be implemented I know you wrote to the
prime minister with your concerns about
that
um has he written back to you what is
where are you with getting all of those
recommendations implemented well I think
what I was upset about was the fact that
the the Secretary of State didn't come
into Parliament and announced what was
going to happen perception matters and
that's what I wanted to draw the
attention to the Prime Minister he did
write back to me and he did say you know
there are and things going to be
happening but I still felt that he and
he and the Secretary of State should
have gone to the dispatch box and
explained
to the house to the country this is
what's doing because white people
got upset about it as well can they be
trusted to make sure that those
Implement those recommendations are
implemented well I'm just hoping that
the right people get around that table
that's why I say to black people
you have to be sitting around the table
to be part of the decision-making
process if you remember when we had uh
the the euros and the three young men
missed the goal
Marcus rashford's mural was defaced and
it was white people who went there and
cleaned it up and said leave Marcus
alone now we have the whole country
standing up for justice for equality for
for the right equality for the right
thing to happen and when everybody
listens and that's why Windrush day is
so important that's why the 75th
anniversary is so important so we get
the whole country to celebrate the
optimism is infectious and you've
achieved so much thank you very much
thank you